شكرا سفيان مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل
العسكري اللواء فايز دويري اهلا بك لواء
دويري قبل ان نبدا التحليل نتابع الان
بدايه بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه معك عبد القادر نعم
وسيله والعلي انطلق من الشمال بالنظر الى
تطوراته المتلاحقه خلال الساعات الماضيه و
انطلاقا من هذه التطورات يمكن الاشاره الى
تصريحات متلاحقه لقاده عسكريين اسرائيليين
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث عن
هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن منطقه الشمال التي
لطالما كانت مسرحا لمواجهات واشتباكات
قادتها المقاومه خصوصا على محاور عديده
على مستوى محور جباليا وايضا على مستوى
المحاور الشماليه في بيت حنون مخيم جباليه
على مستوى منطقه الشجاعيه حديث المتحدث
العسكري لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا في تقليص او بدا يتراجع
نوعا ما يراجع كثافه حضوره على مستوى هذه
المحاور نذكر بان هذا المحور كان قد شهد
توغلات اسرائيليه على اكثر من جهه وجبهه
كان هناك محاوله للتقدم بالاساس نحو غرب
مخيم جباليه كان هناك ايضا توغل للاليات
الاسرائيليه بدايه نحو هذه المناطق لكن
الجديد هو هذا الحديث الاسرائيلي عن اعاده
النظر ويحتاج طبعا الى تحليل عسكري اعاده
النظر في وجوده في هذه المناطق التي بقدر
ما شهدت عمليات قصف مكثفه وايضا عمليه
تدمير للمباني واستهداف للمدنيين الا انها
شهدت ايضا معارك خاضتها المقاومه على اكثر
من صعيد اذا هذا ما يحدث في الشمال مع
حديث مراسلنا ايضا عن بدء الجيش
الاسرائيلي في نصب نوع نقاط تفتيش
بالتحديد في منطقه الشيخ عجلين لو ذهبنا
الى المنطقه الوسطى وحينما نتحدث عن
المنطقه الوسطى نحن نشير بالاساس الى
مخيمات لطالما شهدت عمليه قصف مكثف ولا
زالت خصوصا اليوم شهدنا عمليه قصف استهدفت
النصيرات البريج والمغازي ولكن ايضا منطقه
الزوايده هذا القصف ايضا ياتي بينما كانت
الونر وقد اعلنت بان اكثر من مليون و900
ال نازح منذ السبعه وال اكتوبر 7ب من
اكتوبر في كل قطاع غزه وحينما نتابع
عمليات القصف المكثفه للمنطقه الوسطى ياتي
ذلك بينما في ظل ما عاشته المناطق
الشماليه ولكن ايضا في ظل الاشتباكات
المتواصله في المنطقه الجنوبيه وتساؤلات
اين يذهب المدنيون النازحون في ظل عمليه
القصف المكثف وما دلالات هذا القصف المكثف
لهذه المناطق لو انتقلنا الى المنطقه
الاخرى وهي المنطقه الجنوبيه ولعل هي
المنطقه التي تشهد اشتباكات مكثفه خصوصا
امام خصوصا في المناطق الشرقيه والمناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه من خان يونس هناك
اشتباكات مكثفه تاخذها المقاومه ولكن ايضا
هناك قصف مكثف بالاساس للمناطق الشرقيه
والمناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه وتحديدا كان
هناك اشتباكات نقلت تاخذها المقاومه
تحديدا في محور كليه العلوم والتكنولوجيا
هذه التطورات على هذه الجبهات تاتي بينما
ننتقل الى جبهه اخرى شهدت تطورا لافت وهي
من خلال عمليه الاستهداف بطائره مسيره
واستهدفت سياره لاحد القاده الميدانيين
لحزب الله هناك في منطقه خربه سلم في في
الجنوب اللبناني
وسام
الذي وسام طويل الذي تم اغتياله من خلال
عمليه قصف بطائره مسيره في هذه المنطقه
وحينما نتحدث عن استهداف خربه سلم فنحن
نتابع ايضا عمليات اشتباك مكثفه وسط
تساؤلات هنا وعمليات قصف مكثفه لمناطق في
الجنوب اللبناني وسط تساؤلات عن قواعد
الاشتباك بعد عمليه الاغتيال التي تاتي
ايضا بعد الاغتيال الذي طال القائد في
القسام العاروري في في جنوب لبنان اذا
تطورات لافته على اكثر من صعيد وسيله لعل
التطورات في الشمال وحديث الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن مقاربه جديده لوجوده هناك
تحتاج الى تحليل عسكري معمق بالفعل عبد
القادر ومن هنا سننطلق مع اللواء الدويري
كانت هناك كان هناك تضارب في الانباء خلال
الايام الماضيه يبدو ان الموضوع حسم من
قبل الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي الذي يتحدث
عن كثافه ان كثافه العمليات في الشمال
ستتراجع سحب للقوات كذلك ما الذي نفهمه من
كلامه يعني كان هناك تضارب في التصريحات
لكن احنا نتحدث منذ عده ايام عن مجريات
المعركه واشرت في اكثر من مقاربه بان هناك
انسحابات
تجري بدات في الغرب من الشيخ رضوان
والرمال وما شابه ذلك ثم بدا التخفيف في
المنطقه الشرقيه وتحدثنا قبل عده ايام
قلنا
بان عمليه التراجع في الدرج في التفاح في
الجنوب الشرقي من الجباليه من الشجاعيه من
التفاح كانت تجري على قدم وساق وكانت
مضنيه يعني حتى انا اسمتها عمليه فك
الاشتباك كانت مكلفه وباهظ لجيش الاحتلال
وتم عرض فيديوها
مكثفه في تلك الفتره معظمها من الشجاعيه
والتفاح عن
والدرج وكان حتى يوم امس حتى يوم امس كان
التواجد الفعلي من منظور قتالي متحرك كان
فقط في جبل الرئيس وقلنا بان هذه القوات
ستعيد تموضعها وحجمها اربعه الويه وطرحنا
تساؤل اين ستعيد تموضعها غزه هل هي داخل
قطاع غزه ام خارج غلاف غزه فقلت جحر الديك
يكون حاضر في الذهنيه لجيش الاحتلال اذا
ما اعادت موضعه في داخل داخل قطاع غزه
فالمعركة ولكن هذا لا يعني التخلي عن
تنفيذ عمليات سواء بالقصف المدفعي قصف
الصاروخي القصف الجوي او الدخول الارضي
سيبقى يدفع بقواته خاصه هناك ثلاثه نقاط
اساسيه سيب سيحاول ان يبقي على وجود مؤقت
ولكنه متكرر وهما يعني انشاء الحواجز
ونقاط التفتيش وهذه ستكون على حسب قراءتي
على شارع الرشيد على شارع صلاح الدين وفي
وادي غزه في وادي غزه طيب لواء دويري اذا
ما انسحبت هذه القوات الى غلاف غزه وبما
ان المقاومه ما تزال قادره على اطلاق
الصواريخ من الشمال الى غلاف غزه الا تصبح
سهله الاستهداف في هذه الحاله الان نعم
ستبقى لكن السؤال اي يعني هذه القوات
بحاجه الى اعاده تاهيل واعاده بناء
الجاهزيه قد تذهب الى مناطق خلفيه في
منطقه ما بعد الغلاف كما جرى مع اللواء
جولاني عندما انسحب تم اعاده تاهيله اخذ
تقريبا حوالي اسبوعين اطار زمني وتم الزج
به بالجنوب فهذه القوات هذه القوات التي
سحبت سيتم اعاده تاهيلها واعاده رفع
جاهزيتها انا ارى سون اتجاه عملها مرتبط
بما يجري في الجبهه الشماليه الجبهه
الشماليه تم احضار بعض الالويه منها
اللواء لواء جولاني هو يعود للجبهه
الشماليه الان بعد ما جرى من
استهداف
للطويل س قد يكون هناك تدحرج في اليه
الصراع وهذا قد يجبر الجيش على ان يسحب
الان هناك تقريبا 25% من القوه ابقي عليها
في الشمال
قد يتم الان اعاده القوه التي سحبت من
الشمال وتعزيزها ببعض الالويه اتذكرين
تم تسريح خمسه الويه والان نتحدث عن اربعه
الويه سحبت بصوره كبيره جدا اذا نتحدث عن
تسعه الويه هذه التسعه الويه اين سيكون
توجهها المنطقه الجنوبيه يوجد بها كثافه
من القوات قد لا تحتاج الى ذلك وهذا ما
نشاهده الان المنطقه الجنوبيه التي تشهد
معارك ضاريه الغارات لم تتوقف
والاشتباكات كذلك ما دلاله ال مكان اليوم
الذي يشهد هذه الاشتباكات نتحدث عن تقريبا
المعارك من خلال الثلاث ايام الماضيه لم
تتغير خطوط
الاشتباك خلال الثلاث ايام الماضيه لم
خطوط الاشتباك شبه ثابته
باستثناء تغيرات طفيفه جدا لانه اولا
العمليه حكينا عنها كثيرا تم بعد فشل
اجراء عمليه التطويق الشامل وظهور القراره
وخزاعه كنقاط مزعجه جدا لقوات الاحتلال تم
اعاده قوه للتعامل مع القراره ووسعت اول
من امس العمليات باتجاه الزنه وارسلت لواء
كامل للتعامل مع خزاعه وبقيت بقيه
القوات تحمي او تتموضع على الا اتاف
الشماليه
لعبس الجديده وعبس الكبيره وجنوب بني سيلا
في الجزء الغربي غرب طريق صلاح
الدين دخلت من منطقه المواصي الى ثلاثه
نقاط منطقه الكتيبه والمحطه والسجن وثبتت
خطوط الاشتباك في تلك المنطقه ويجري
القتال بمقاربات عما كان يجري في منطقه
مدينه غزه وما حولها لانه هنا الواقع
المخت متلف جدا من حيث نوع الانفاق وعدد
الانفاق وعدد الفتحات وبدا القتال
بمجموعات صغيره شبه متحركه منها ما يعمل
معركه صداميه منها ما يعمل بالعمق
فبالتالي لا تغيير جوهري على الوضع العام
للمعركه في هذه المنطقه منذ ثلاثه ايام
فقط العلامه المميزه الكثافه الناريه
التدمير الممنهج خاصه في خزاعه وطبعا هنا
نذكر بما قاله جالانت بان المرحله هي
اقتربنا من المرحله التاليه من الحرب بما
فيها في مدينه غزه اشكرك جزيل الشكر لواء
فايز الدويري ضيفنا هنا في الاستديو ختام
هذه النافذه العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل
على غزه نعود الان الى غرفه الاخبار واليك
سفيان من جديد